so we have a circle here and they
specified some points for us this little
orangish or i guess maroonish red point
right over here is the circle is the
center of the circle and then this blue
point is a point that happens to sit on
the circle and so with that information
i want you to pause the video and see if
you can figure out the equation for this
circle
all right let's work through this
together so let's first think about the
center of the circle and the center of
the circle is just going to be the
coordinates of that point so the x
coordinate is negative 1 and then the y
coordinate is 1. so center is negative 1
comma 1.
and now let's think about what the
radius of the circle is well the radius
is going to be the distance between the
center and any point on the circle so
for example
for example this distance
the distance of that line let's see i
could do a thicker a thicker version of
that
this this
this line right over there something
strange about
my
something strange about my
pen tools making that very thin let me
do it one more time
okay that's better the distance of that
line right over there that is going to
be the radius so how can we figure that
out
well we can set up a right triangle and
essentially use the distance formula
which comes from the pythagorean theorem
to figure out the length of that line so
this is the radius
we could figure out
a change in
x
so if we look at our change in x right
over here
our change in x as we go from the center
to this point
so this is our change in x
and then we could say that this is our
change in y
that right over there is our change in y
and so our change in x squared plus our
change in y squared is going to be our
radius squared that comes straight out
of the pythagorean theorem this is a
right triangle and so we can say that
r squared is going to be equal to our
change
in x
squared
plus our change in y squared
plus our change in y squared now what is
our change in x square or what is our
change in x going to be our change in x
is going to be equal to
well when we go from the radius to this
point over here our x goes from negative
to 6. so you can view it as our ending x
minus our starting x
so negative 1 minus negative sorry 6
minus negative 1 is equal to
7.
so
let me
we have
our change in x this right over here is
equal to
seven if we viewed
this as the start point and this is the
end point it would be negative seven but
we really care about the absolute value
of the change in x and once you square
it it all becomes a positive anyway so
our change in x right over here is going
to be positive 7
and our change in y
well we are starting at
we are starting at y is equal to one and
we are going to y is equal to negative
four so it would be negative four
minus one
which is equal to negative
five and so our change in y is negative
five you could view this distance right
over here as the absolute value of our
change in y
which of course would be the absolute
value
of 5 but once you square it it doesn't
matter the negative sign goes away and
so this is going to simplify to 7
squared change in x squared is 49
change in y squared negative 5 squared
is 25
so we get r squared
we get r squared is equal to 49 plus 25
so what's 49 plus 25 let's see that's
going to be 54 was it 74
r squared is
equal to
74. did i do that right yep 74. and so
now we can write the equation for the
circle the circle is going to be all of
the points that are
well and like let me write the so if r
squared is equal to 74
r is equal to the square root of 74.
and so the equation circle is going to
be all points x comma y that are this
far away from the center and so what are
those points going to be
well the distance is going to be x minus
the x coordinate of the center
x minus
negative 1
squared
let me do that in a blue color
minus negative 1
squared
plus
y
minus
y minus the y coordinate of the center
y minus 1
squared
squared is equal
is going to be equal to r squared is
going to be equal to the length of the
radius squared well r squared we already
know is going to be 74.
74. and then if we want to simplify a
little bit you subtract a negative this
becomes a positive
so it simplifies to x plus 1
squared plus
y minus 1 squared
is equal to
is equal to 74
and we are all done